up guys welcome to the just Charlie
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to I debunked the entire
manosphere before I start don't forget
to subscribe to the channel and bring
that notification Bell that we are going
to be notified of my daily videos also
guys if you want to know what my
producer blessing looks like send a
super thanks
he's camera shy today we're going to be
talking about hyperbole forms of female
hyperness the word hypergamy or
hypergamy on this part oh my gosh Rolo
looks so different there oh my goodness
yes we don't cry about hypergamy this is
a huge subject human females engage in
hyper women mate across and up dominance
with a small percentage of men hogging a
large percentage of women we can't get
rid of that hypergamous nature and then
just leave the men at the bottom to be
Cast Away that's terrific it's widely
accepted that women are hypergamous
that's it first of all let's look at the
supposed evidence that they have for
hypergamy this is a study which revealed
that 5 000 years ago after the rise of
Agriculture a huge uptick in wealth
disparity meant that there were a small
group of very rich alpha males that
reproduced with on average 17 women
cooking the rest of men into a sexless
Oblivion to deal with this we developed
the monogamous system which in short no
man was left out of the reproductive I
assure you there are still men left out
of the reproductive Market S I assure
you I assure you sexual Marketplace this
was an example of women's ingrained
hypergamous nature at its peak and if we
allow the current sexual Marketplace to
expand to its natural conclusion it will
all happen once again you know they were
the incels of thousands of years ago
they were the original right so they
they might group up to rebel against the
Chad and they will take the women and
separate them among themselves the
marxists for example they came to
America and they destroyed thousands of
years of cultural Evolution we live in a
primitive sexual Market yeah just like
it existed thousands of years ago for a
start there is no consideration that
this may have not been the women's
Choice many of these powerful Alphas
were probably r wording the women in all
reality and not allowing her any choice
in her mating preference whatsoever one
of the things your research has
indicated is that there is a manner in
which women see like that's a very
modern woman mindset well if women were
doing that then it must be man's fault
they must have been R wording them
unless she has some study that by and
large that was happening I I'm always
open to new information I I hope she
brings me something that I don't know in
this genuinely but okay are attracted to
people who manifest dark Triad traits
yeah I would say I would add the
qualifier that it tends to be younger
teenagers or women in their early 20s
there is no modern day evidence that
women prefer Bad Boys
um okay
I'll give you a piece of this is a piece
of anecdotal evidence I had an only fans
a male only fans model on my show he
said one of the number one things that
women request is grape scene I've also
done more interviews than I could count
I also have an anecdotal experience just
from talking to friends yeah women women
do like bad boys stop cabin let's just
stop capping either when they're
ovulating or when they're not there's
actually more evidence to prove the
opposite oh I'm interested okay
um physical attract two women prefer
dominating autism is she gonna go into
these because here's the thing it's like
women
tend to sleep with the bad boys they
might marry the nice guy there is
evidence that women are attracted to men
with dark Triad traits but one of these
traits is narcissism which correlates
with physical attractiveness and
extroversion and in much the same way
men are attracted to women with dark
Triad traits as narcissism correlates
with physical attractiveness so once
well you realize narcissism is it like
you can't make um conclusions about
Society at large what percent of the
population
is a narcissist I'm seeing it one
percent one to five percent of the
population the physical attractiveness
and the confidence is controlled for
dark Triad traits actually add nothing
for either gender basically you can be
confident and nice and you'll still be
attractive to women and never take
dating advice from women
we don't even know what we want men but
this doesn't stop JP stomping around
podcasts talking about this like it's
science-based fact the only other
evidence they have for this is the I'll
give you a piece of evidence
women reproduce more with non-violent
offenders than men or women reproduce
more with violent offenders than
non-violent offenders pop Evo psych
evidence which has not been proven to
the point of peer-reviewed consensus
Peterson will maintain this yeah this is
the crazy thing is I feel like a lot of
stuff that's just
like we Ben knew that women don't like
nice guys we Bend you like there's
always the crazy high school boyfriend
it's always like girls date The Bad Boys
in their early 20s when they get closer
to getting that ring they'll marry the
nice guy almost culturally women have
always dated across and all yeah only 40
of men have reproduced historically so
yes that's true females engage in
hypergamy and hypergamy as the Ten this
is also true cross-culturally and it's
also quite uh it's just as extensive in
Scandinavia not quite there's a bit of
attenuation but not much women mate
across and up dominance hierarchies
man-made across and down
okay and that has to be the case because
yeah because men swipe right 45 of the
time on dating apps where women
celebrate five percent of the time up to
20 depends on the study obviously it has
to work that way if one goes up the
other has to go down this is only half
true Peterson consistently fails to
point out the hordes of studies that
show that hypergamy is much less
prominent in more developed countries
because as an economy develops and is
able to provide social safety nets and
less children die at a young age they
will have less children at an older age
as it is safer to do so true they will
have less children at an older age what
is that after women still swipe right
five percent of the time on dating app
you cannot tell me
that women don't date across and up oh
come on come on I make so many girls
come on my show and tell me I don't even
know what study she's talking about I
would be look at
they want to date a guy that makes more
money than them that's taller than them
that's smarter than them that's in
better shape than them ideally ideally
men swipe right 45 of the time on dating
apps and they will choose a spouse later
in life based on that's true but you
know what's interesting even the women
that say they don't want to get married
I always ask for the right guy would you
get married and have kids and they
always say yes and so to me that
indicates they just can't get the guy
that they want yeah first marriage is I
said 27 I actually I thought it was
closer to 30 now needs such as emotional
needs you're probably not familiar with
this concept Jordan but people are
finding other people that actually like
them so I don't know this kind of sounds
like a much better solution for all
genders rather than trapping people into
marriages they entered for the needs of
bearing children and economics ominous
always have this like trapping like it's
like the language they use trapping
people into marriages for children and
it's like it's like we we always have
this like worst case scenario in our
minds our feminists do stability but
that's apparently the red pilled Utopia
that we're all striving for Peterson and
his incel minions also don't account for
the fact that men on average thanks to
Millennia of patriarchy earn more than
women still so oh my God oh my God she
why I I can't believe people don't know
about the pig app in 2022 that they
don't know the reasons why the pig app
exists women make or make less than men
because we don't work as hard I'm sorry
and I can say this from hiring people I
I could say this from hiring people
the people that put in the most my
employees that put in the most hours are
men men work more the reason women get
paid less for the same job is because
they work Less hours and they tend to
negotiate less it's not surprising that
we're still living with the Norms of a
husband earning more than a why divorce
rates are actually lower than ever
because marriage rates are lower than
ever divorce rates are lower than ever
it's still like 50 I don't think divorce
rates are lower than ever because it's
50 and I know in the 1920s it was like
20 because people are actually waiting
to find and who's whose choice is that
men or women men are attracted to
fertility and youth so whose choice is
it to wait to get married men or women
when they actually [__] like
I don't know you might say that I think
it's because they're running out of time
they are running out of time girls would
be like I don't need no man I ain't
submissive that at 28 to 30. she's like
oh I was just talking
I don't even know I
I was just talking I swear to God I was
just talking I didn't mean any of that
later in life after their frontal lobes
are fully formed and this is actually
decreasing the chances of younger less
wealthy men being left with nobody and
of old females spinsters being left with
nobody but um
if that was effective why is it when the
age of first marriage goes up divorce
rates have also gone up hang on a minute
say the incels there is evidence that
women are initiating divorces when they
get promoted this means they're looking
for higher status Men We Tell guys all
the time that marriage isn't really a
good institution in the United States
and a woman choosing a bartender who is
broke over a rich guy is just so far
removed from reality concept is known as
monkey brunch 70 of all marriages end
because the woman petitioned to have it
because it's set up so that the one with
less money is the one who gets spousal
support because they've been
incentivized to do so because of the
wealth transfer for women like the
richest women in the world either got
their money through inheritance or they
got it through divorce they just want to
protect themselves that's generally why
they do a woman breaks up in order to
trade up you could struggle with you or
I could take this money that the
government's giving me and all I gotta
do is sleep with you ultimately this can
also be her searching for a bigger
better option they believe they've got
relation ship Equity that they can make
a withdrawal on at a later date women do
initiate more divorces now because when
they feel that they can support
themselves they are less likely to trap
themselves in an unhappy marriage in
which they are expected to do most of
the household chores causing them stress
so you ended a marriage over chores
and this is what I mean this is what I
meant to want to get married you
you did divorce a man over chores
blessing blessing come here come here
chores can you imagine getting divorced
over chores yeah yeah she was like women
are more likely to divorce when they get
promoted because they're less likely
they can support themselves so they're
they're not as likely to stay in a happy
marriage or an unhappy marriage where
maybe the chores are stressing her out
oh my goodness evidence that they are
leaving them for higher value males
there is also another apparently hard to
swallow pill that women I mean okay
let's just let's just be real here when
women leave are they expecting to do
worse why would you leave someone and
accept and expect to do worse but I'm
just be real and we'll cheat on their
beta male husbands with Alphas another
theory that Peterson backs up with you
because there's two different mating
strategies for women there's like the
guy you're physically attracted to and
the guy that you can see yourself with
long term and that's more of like the
provider type it's very hard to find
both some guys have both and you know
that's why I mean like
Gisele what's her face what what she do
after Tom Brady the Jiu Jitsu instructor
the further I'm not saying anything for
this or against this this is a purely
factual biological clip is they pick a
monogamous marriage and they cheat with
high status guys
now you know obviously in the confines
of the marriage that's a terrible thing
but that's a very uncomfortable subject
though for women in particular
uncomfortable subject for everyone right
is there any evidence to back this up
absolutely not from survey data men
admit to cheating on their spouses more
than women but the women it's actually
really similar the more recent studies
that have come out
um it's very similar in terms of
cheating data but it's interesting
because if men cheat they still are
equally likely to rate their marriages
happy or if women cheat
um it's interesting a lot of them want
to get caught and they also are more
likely to rate their marriages as
unhappy while catching up with the men
because the most common way for someone
to cheat is with someone they know like
a work call wait wait so then okay this
is kind of proven what she said a work
colleague so a higher status male after
she gets the promotion so now women have
been allowed to leave the house more
they're actually beginning to cheat as
much as men do but there's no ever
evidence that they've ever cheated more
than men and it's still I know I swear I
just saw a study the other day well not
the norm to cheat either like it's
somehow become socially acceptable
there's no societal shift away from
monogamy we still want to get married or
settle a long time ah we want to but we
won't 45 of women between the ages of 25
and 45 will be single and childless so
if we want to why aren't we there's
always there's always a man that will
marry a woman in relationships humans
pair bond that's what we mostly do we're
just doing it later when we're settled
in life
hmm
um if that was effective why are we more
divorced now furthermore there is no
survey data that shows that the women
who do cheat are doing so with high
status men what you're cheating with a
guy that's uglier and Broker Than your
husband that's offensive oh that's a
goodbye if we're going to talk about
this through a pop Evo psych lens surely
it's more evolutionary advantageous for
a woman not to be hypergamous and to be
wary of the risk of getting involved
with the wrong man who will not support
her child since the woman has always
been the most I will not support your
child I'm so confused Collective gender
she's always had a choice between a beta
or an alpha no but now now the
government funds her choice that's the
difference I'm not saying like women
have are any different today than
they've always been now they get paid to
do it so a girl can have a kid with the
alpha instead of going for the provider
there's more of a consequence for going
for or the alpha or there's less of a
consequence for going for the alpha so
basically she can have a kid with them
and then rely on the government and
they'll pay her to be a single mother
especially here they used to I don't
know if they still do here in the UK but
they'll give you free housing so why
would she willingly put herself in the
dangers of an aggressive violent Alpha
not all Alphas are aggressive it just
means like good genes hot guy
leave her children without her father I
don't know I don't know but I I'm
telling you I've met so many girls that
have done that exact thing that have
done the exact thing that break up her
home and become a single mother for no
good reason maybe if we're doing chores
for doing chores why not just settle
down with the beta from day one who will
protect her from all of the praying
Alphas because like women want the
alphas but they can't I mean think about
if you're a top 10 guy in terms of looks
what incentive do you have to settle
down well your most girlfriends will let
you cheat these red pill men are simply
projecting how they see that it's like
who do you think knows more about dating
women men or women men or women who do
you think knows more so if all the guys
are saying these are my observations
instead of saying you're wrong maybe you
could listen to them and you might learn
something knock it onto women when women
actually see it very differently take it
from me if a man walks up to me and asks
me for my number or asks me on a date
I'm not thinking oh wow I wonder if he
has a nice car yeah but you might say
what do you do for a living what is your
job I wonder and I wonder if that's more
expensive than my current voice it's
more expensive than my current boyfriend
right right you might not be thinking
that like you might not mean to but
you know damn well you have it look you
know you know damn well that girls are
not looking to leave their boyfriends
and do worse they're not looking to
leave their boyfriends and do worse for
their husbands whatever I'm thinking I
hope this interaction ends without this
man getting there it is there it is
there it is all men are angry violent
angry men three violent all following me
home fear fear mentality I guessing
involved with the red pill and by
learning game you're literally giving
yourself a 101 on how to give women
every red flag oh my God he looks so
nervous in this you seem like touching
his arms
um whatever you in the [__] book to
learn how to a game is just learning how
to talk to women by far the most
tangible evidence the manosphere has for
modern day hypergamy I just say dating
apps oh my gosh it is from dating apps
there we go yeah that's it data from
dating apps which is the number one way
people our meeting nowadays account for
you know the Plenty of Fish data the
tender data that we have men do not get
nearly as many options as women and even
if we're talking about top tier guys
they still cannot compete since deleted
2009 official blog post and okay Cupids
showed women fading men as worse looking
than medium eighty percent of the time
most of the men on Tinder of the
profiles they come across females
they'll swipe right on from 60 of them
when it comes to females they'll only
swipe right in 4.5 4.5 these guys you
look at okay Cupid's data yeah and they
behave a certain way on Tinder uh yes
women let me gosh she's gonna try to
discredit it by saying like oh people
aren't looking for relationships on
dating apps
well it's dating apps but for even if we
tripled it that's 15 of men they they
like you know swipe right they like the
profiles of only four percent men when
they see female profiles they swipe
right or like uh more than 60 percent
that's a great example of hypergamy time
to get debunked again you like this
being thoroughly debunked by a vagina
have a with a second class degree a
music production there was one Infamous
blog post made by OkCupid in 2009 which
supposedly exposed the hypergamous
nature of women it showed that women
rated 80 of men on the website as below
average in attractiveness whereas men's
ratings for women's attractiveness
resemble more of an equalized bell curve
they jumped on this as proof of their
perito principle it's generally believed
that this is one of the main catalysts
of the modern in-cell movement and
another piece of evidence is who women
choose to reproduce with women have only
are women men have only produced 40
percent of the time historically the
blog post was eventually taken down not
long after the incel attack in Toronto
where 11 people died the incels took
this to mean that big Tech was trying to
hide the truth of hypergamy ironic what
about what about when a woman chops a
man's off that's happened
and they laughed about it on National
Television so it's just interesting how
when something's a gendered crime men
they don't care when it's men they only
care when it's women Lee that same blog
post actually showed that women are more
likely to be open to messaging men they
see as less attractive whereas men are
more likely to only message women they
rate as more attractive to themselves
but that still doesn't take away the
fact that they only match with five
percent they might be less attractive
but they're still going to be in the top
15 percent so it showed that even though
women rate most manners below average
they are much more likely to message
them anyway so here we are again with
the incel projection of shallow dating
you can't message you if you don't match
preferences on women in addition to this
our slash Tinder data generally tends to
show that men will swipe right on most
women and women will be very picky and
the ones that they do swipe right on
will very likely result in a I need to
explain why this is the case a fact that
the red pill seems to gloss over is that
women are always going to be more picky
than men when it comes to dating due to
the increased risk of violence and
pregnancy not because of hypergamy let
her
The increased risk of violence and
pregnancy okay let me let's have a look
at some stats that the monosphere
completely ignores okay before she goes
into this men are more likely most most
Mutual domestic violence most domestic
violence cases it's mutual meaning
they're hitting each other men are more
likely to get hit by women one-sided
than women are to get hit by men I just
like to say that women who have used
dating sites or raps are especially
likely to report having negative
interactions with others on these
platforms a majority of female online
daters younger than 50 say harassment
unsolicited explicit messages are very
common on dating platforms sixty percent
of female users aged 18 to 34 say
someone on a dating site or app continue
to contact them after they said they
were not interested while a similar
share 57 report being sent a sexually
explicit message or image that they
didn't ask for roughly half of women
think dating on sites or apps are an
unsafe way to meet people okay more more
picky fine I'll give you 20 I'll give
you 30 but five for four point five
percent you don't think that means
anything roughly half of women think
dating on sites or apps are an unsafe
way to meet people more under 20s is
such and why are you on the dating app
if you don't think it's safe then get
off
if they thought it was an unsafe way to
be meet people then not want to be the
number one way people are meeting
resulted after meeting okay okay okay
671 cases out of how how many people in
the I'm just saying the odds I don't
know what the odds are because it
doesn't say 671 cases like is that in
the whole Us in in a year like that's a
lot of that's a lot of that's like not
I'm not trying to be an [__] I'm just
like it's really not a lot when you
think of how big the population victims
and 83 of the 671 cases were female and
17 were male oh and I'm not done yet
here's a full report from ABC about
tindus failure to act on essay reports
of the 48 people they found who reported
essay to the app only 11 even got a
response from Tinder almost all of those
responses did not detail whether any
action was taken and match group the
company that owns basically everything
Tinder OkCupid match.com hinge Plenty of
Fish and some others has openly admitted
that they do not screen for sexual
predators on their free apps a
spokesperson said there are definitely
registered sex offenders on our free
products which is a bit like a
spokesperson for an ice cream company
saying there are definitely fleshy well
I mean I'm not trying to be rude it's
just like duh
are there creeps on dating apps yeah duh
being spiders in some tubs but this kind
of goes back to like the Modern Woman
fear mentality like if you're always
thinking of the worst possible scenario
it's like what do they say it's like
it's like you're going and dating into a
place of fear is that really what you
want to be doing of our ice cream don't
blame me I just work here so look at you
ladies while Tinder makes men pay for
the slight hope of more matches you'll
have to pay for the assurance that you
won't be assaulted I'm sorry there is
never a hundred percent assurance that
you won't be assaulted it doesn't matter
if you meet someone on the street or you
meet someone on an app there's never 100
guarantee all you can do is take
precautions but I I promise you also I'd
like to say point out to a study that
was done there's a guy that put that he
was a he put a model picture and put
that he was a sex offender like he he's
essayed a 15 year old or something girls
didn't care they didn't give a [__] they
literally got messed and even then it's
not good on top of that if women were
afraid of being assaulted why are y'all
having kids with violent offenders
indeed I cannot stress this enough
dating apps do not represent real life
dating apps represent they're the number
one way people are meeting an extremely
shallow gamified version of dating that
artificially creates the burrito
principle since women are more no
don't think so I think dating apps are
just letting women be honest like if
they could have everything if we could
have everything we wanted in a man like
the filters will let us do it eighty
percent of women put height filters on
so they won't date a guy below six foot
I need to have had previous negative
experiences so maybe on an app it's five
percent maybe in real life let's let's
quadruple it and say it's 20 that's
still only twenty percent of men with
men I'm not discounting that men have
them too but the fact that women have
them more often than men is relevant
here so women are more likely to have
their guards up when swiping it's so
interesting feminists always want to
take like the accountability off of
women and like whenever there's an
unflattering fact about women it's
always like oh it's because of men and
chatting so this causes men to get less
matches on the ladies that they're
swiping right on and the men are getting
annoyed that they're getting less
matches because this leads to less of a
chance that they'll find someone that
they like to them this just becomes a
numbers game so they start swiping right
light on more and more and more women
and the women start to realize that
whoever they swipe right on they're
quite likely to get a match with them
and because they don't want too many
unsolicited pictures of male genitalia
taken with a pissy toilet bowl in the
background to deal with the lady come on
I promise to God if I swipe left on a
dating app it is not because I'm afraid
I'm gonna get an unsolicited dick pic if
that's what you're afraid of get off
dating apps go maybe one person if
that's what you want and there's no
guarantee anywhere that could happen
but you're gonna say oh
stop being more picky confident that
this won't matter because they'll still
get a lot of matches anyway as the women
get more picky the men get less and less
picky it's a yeah yeah that's true as
women get more picky men get less and
less picky yeah men are as picky as
their options they're really not
negative feedback loop it's not real
life and see okay I used to think that
like oh it's not real life I would I
would argue that women are less picky in
person I would agree but again even if
it's five percent a week quadruplet
that's still 20 let's up it to 30 and
then I just started like walking into a
room and noticing like which guys I
would want to date in that room and I
was like oh my gosh it really is a small
percent of men is that that red pill
seems to ignore 80 of uses on Tinder are
male and 20 are female the bad
experiences are causing women to leave
the apps that's an interesting it's an
interesting stat I think men just
need it more all together this means
that there are women out there guess
what in real life who are single and
want to meet somebody but you know what
the number one dating app is Instagram
Instagram dating app from the incel
perspective women are hypergamous
through alculating and uncaring as they
leverage emerging technology in the
pursuit of the ideal masculine partner
while maximizing the resources they
yield from orbiters women are also oh
that's so true come on come on the
friend zone the friends simultaneously
sexual Commodities which can be
quantitatively evaluated subject to
Market distortions or be unfairly
distributed here in cells doubly deny
women their Humanity as women are
manipulative when acting and overpriced
when objectified while in cells
observations are accurate they're
explanations for these observations are
grounded in a reductive and dehumanizing
descriptions of oh so it says why in
cells are surveillance so our study says
we're right with men and women all of a
sudden communism doesn't sound so bad to
these guys when it means the equal
distribution of getting in quit another
no
that's not what guys are saying I mean I
think saying to a women you know top
five percent of men when you're an
average chick probably is it realistic I
don't really think that's a dehumana
graph that they love to point to is this
one which shows that almost a third of
men are now reporting No Sex in the last
year but zooming out and looking at the
rest of this data that this graph comes
from it shows that the amount of men
sleeping with over three women in the
last year is still more than the amount
of women doing the same on the whole men
are still being more promiscuous small
percentage of men small percentage than
women which doesn't track with their 80
of women sleeping with all of the Chad's
Theory the data would suggest to me that
women still want relationships with men
but men are increasingly attempting I'm
actually glad she brought studies this
is interesting although it makes that
would still make sense with the Chad
Theory the dating apps for hookups but
are ending up more lonely than they were
before in short guys gals and NBS try
opening yourself up to experiences which
will help you meet people in real life
make I agree with that person's with
people of all genders more talk to
people even if you don't find them
attractive because who knows they could
even introduce you to other people you
may end up being intimate partners with
or maybe you've just found a new friend
it's about self-improvement exercising
your social muscle and fighting that
inner Goblin that just wants to stay
inside feminists always paint this like
scary picture of the world for women and
I just disagree and I think it's silly
to say that women are not hypergamous
when only 40 of men have reproduced
historically uh most women want to date
a guy that makes more money most women
want to date a guy taller than them most
women go on a date against smarter than
them If you deny that you're just
denying reality if you want to wonder if
Chads are sleeping with all the women
just look at an NBA team and ask
yourself how many guys they sleep with
the guys on those teams rappers
entertain or sleep with in a month
probably more than most men will sleep
with in their lifetime you can also look
at Genghis Khan man had a lot of kids
anyways let me know in the comments what
you guys think um subscribe to the
channel ring that notification Bell and
I'll talk to you next time
[Music]